[Музика]
Привіт усім, настав час уроку англійської,
мене звати Наталія Лесько, давайте
почнемо сьогодні, ми продовжуємо розмову про
школу та освіту, тож давайте почнемо зі
школи та давайте переглянемо предмети та
різні класи давайте почнемо
з предметів давайте  перейдіть із
зображеннями подивіться на цю картинку
це фотографії наших уроків у so grains
cache : лайм, тож ви можете вгадати
предмет так це урок фізкультури добре,
давайте з цим, чи можете ви вгадати
предмет, це не математика, а це  не
хімія, що це за
браво, це фізика, давайте йти далі,
ви здогадаєтеся, це вчитель
пише багато формул на дошці, і
за формулами ви можете здогадатися,
що це також фізика, добре
зроблено, давайте рухатися далі, спробуйте вгадати це
предмет ви бачите я бачу вчителя я
бачу земну кулю і я бачу деякі імена
на дошці, наприклад Австралія, добре, то
що це за
географія Браво, давайте йти далі, чи можете ви
здогадатися, що цей предмет заплутує для
Я, тому що я бачу назву
теми, а вони нічого не бачать на
дошці, але подивіться на
ці три пляшки перед
учителем, вони можуть вам допомогти, так що Браво,
це урок хімії, а що з
цим малюнком,
так  є вчителька і вона стоїть
у відображенні проектора і каже, я
бачу текст, текст український,
тому, ймовірно, це українська мова або
українська література, що ви думаєте,
мм-хм,
я думаю, що це українська література, добре,
а на останньому малюнку є  подивіться на
це знову, клас виглядає як
лабораторія і, ймовірно, це фізика, але
це не панна Ольга, а вона
вчителька англійської мови, тож це
насправді урок англійської мови, у якій
вона мала урок технологій,
тому вона вибрала лабораторію для свого уроку  тому
є завдання для вас подивіться, у нас
є різні предмети, і вони хочуть,
щоб ви вибрали свій улюблений, тому 15
секунд подумайте про ці предмети,
які ваші улюблені ви можете подарувати серця
своїм предметам  приклад, моїм улюбленим
буде англійська для уроку англійської мови
я збираюся дати п'ять сердечок, це мій
улюблений, я люблю це,
тому 15 секунд продовжуйте з
рештою предметів, щоб у вас була власна
піраміда улюблених предметів, давайте
з моїми  top буде
англійською я люблю англійську наступний
буде фізика іноді
насправді дуже важко для мене, що
схоже на більшість англійської чи фізики, тому мені
потрібно вирішити, що вибрати, тому я даю п'ять
сердечок для англійської, а вони дали п'ять
сердечка до уроку фізики давайте перейдемо до
того, що буде далі
українська література я люблю літературу я
люблю читати
і я люблю зарубіжну літературу,
але українська література моя улюблена,
тому я віддам чотири серця за
українську літературу давайте йти далі у нас
є  Уроки хімії, географії та фізкультури
залишилися, тож моїм наступним буде
географія
Мені подобається географія вивчати
різні континенти, погоду,
землю та інші країни, а також
це дуже  цікаво,
так що залишилося три полювання на уроки географії,
хімії та фізкультури, так що два
серця підуть на хімію я в порядку
з хімією я не можу сказати, що мені
це подобається, але я не можу сказати, що ненавиджу, я
просто в порядку
і ми говоримо уроки, мені вони не дуже подобаються,
тому я просто віддам одне серце для
уроків фізкультури, добре, так що давайте покладемо ці
предмети, це піраміда, давайте рухатися далі,
так що англійська і фізика це мій топ
, наступний українська література
потім ми йдемо з географією, хімією і,
нарешті, уроками фізкультури, тому зазвичай, коли ви
говорите про свої улюблені предмети або
свої улюблені речі, ви використовуєте слово мені
подобається мені це дуже подобається мені це подобається мені
це подобається або мені це подобається, але
давайте  подумайте про інтерес до фраз
і соковитої англійської, тож, наприклад, для
англійської та фізики я можу сказати, що я без розуму
від англійської та фізики, я без розуму
від неї, я так люблю, що я
витрачав весь свій час на англійську та фізику,
тож давайте повторимо я  я без розуму ще
раз, я без розуму і з емоціями  s
I'm mad by well done so a all the
word I am mad by English and
physic what about you what you are maught
it is it English also or it is German language or it's math for well done so all the rechen I am mad by English and physic what about you what you are maught it is it engleska as well or it is German language or it's math of well done so all the reposition I am mad by English and physic what about you what you are maught is it also English or to German language or it's math for well done so all the rechen I am mad by English and physic what about you what you are maught is it also English or to German language or it's math for well done so all the word I am mad by English and physic what about you what you are maught it is it engleska as well or it is
German language or it's problem math or
literature or literature or fize classes давайте перейдемо до
української літератури  було моє друге місце,
тому я хотів би використати
фразу подивись я захоплююся для мене
це не так сильно, як безумно тому
я захоплююся українською літературою
мені дуже подобається я захоплююся давайте повторимо я
захоплююся  і ще раз я захоплююся
добре і була ціла фраза я
захоплююся українською літературою
що ти захоплюєшся добре давайте перейдемо до
географії
ладно тому я буду використовувати фразу фантазія я
дуже люблю це те саме, що мені
дуже подобається  так що ще раз мені дуже
подобається, і знову мені дуже подобається фантастика,
дуже дякую і всю фразу
я дуже люблю географію, дякую,
давайте перейдемо до хімії та фізкультури, так що
хімія я сказав вам, що я в порядку з
хімією, тому я збираюся використовувати  цю фразу
я в порядку я в порядку давайте повторимо дякую
ти,
я в порядку з Браво, і вся фраза
я в порядку з хімією, добре,
означає, що я насправді не мені це дуже не подобається,
але я не можу сказати, що я ненавиджу це,
тому ти кажеш, що я  добре, я в порядку з хімією,
що з тобою добре, добре, давайте перейдемо
до уроків фізкультури, тому я не великий фанат фізкультури,
я не можу сказати, що мені це не подобається, тому я
буду використовувати цю фразу  я не великий шанувальник,
тому давайте повторимо, я не великий шанувальник
і ще раз я не великий шанувальник
фантастики, тож давайте скажемо всю фразу,
я не великий шанувальник фізкультури, добре, і ви можете
скажи мені, що ти не великий шанувальник,
дуже дякую, а тепер давайте пограємо в
гру, для якої ми будемо використовувати кубики,
тож давайте подивимося, у нас є
різні числа, а номер один
буде гніватися на номер два
я буду зацікавлений у номері три, модний
номер чотири добре, з номером п'ять великий
фанат, ви можете сказати, що я великий шанувальник, або я
не великий шанувальник, а номер шостий
знову буде крутитися добре, то дозвольте мені показати вам
приклад це виглядає так, якщо ви
скажи номер один, скажи, що номер один означає божевільний
, тому приклад: я без розуму від
біології добре, вам потрібно скласти
власні речення, тож давайте спробуємо, ви
підготуєте кубики, добре, у мене є один, це
цікаво, щоб ви могли повторити моє  приклад, який
я зробив про біологію або скажи свій власний і
злий на англійську. Молодці, давайте спробуємо
ще раз
добре, це п'ять, скажімо, давайте створимо
речення з великим шанувальником, ви можете сказати, що я
великий шанувальник англійської мови, я НЕ великий фанат
фізкультури я  я не великий шанувальник закінченої
мови добре, давайте спробуємо ще раз добре, у мене є
два, так що два захоплюються, чи можете ви скласти
речення з keen on, добре,
я захоплююся алгеброю, я не захоплююся
геометрією, добре зроблено, дякую  дуже багато
зараз давайте запишемо ці речення
добре я пишу на дошці, ви
використовуєте свої нотатки, тому давайте збожеволіти від
номер один
я без розуму від англійської а як щодо вас
добре наступне захоплююся
я захоплююся українською літературою а
ви
Великобританія не таємниці фантазії
Мені дуже подобається географія
вам подобається географія Дякую вам  mber
чотири
добре з
я в порядку з хімією що у вас
добре дякую і останній
номер п'ять великий шанувальник
я не великий шанувальник фізкультури, але я великий
шанувальник фізики добре, а ви
дякую дуже  багато
тепер давайте рухатися далі давайте подивимося
на розклад шкільного розкладу зазвичай у
нас є п'ять днів або тижнів, і у нас є
різні предмети, зараз я
хотів би зіграти з вами в невелику гру,
це буде гра у відгадки, готова
давайте почнемо я  Я дам вам
головоломку, і ви повинні відгадати тему,
яку ви не бачите зображення, це
головоломка, давайте почнемо з першого, чи
можете ви відгадати тему, подивіться на
формулу Браво, це фізика,
тож давайте напишемо назву  з предмета
фізика є одним з моїх улюблених. Я без розуму
від фізики,
тому давайте переглянемо деякі слова, які
пов'язані або пов'язані з фізикою, що
мені спадає на думку,
наприклад, енергія, тож давайте запишемо це
енергія область також у нас є  слова на кшталт
влади і сили влади Патера  nist force
sila окей, у нас також є такі слова, як хвиля
прохолодна і що ще у нас тиск
що таке тиск диск Браво,
тож давайте переглянемо енергія сила сила хвиля
і тиск і всі ці слова
з фізики давайте перейдемо до ще однієї
загадки,
готові, давайте, чи можете ви вгадати
Браво це математика чи алгебра ок давайте
запишемо назву ідеально які слова
асоціюються з алгеброю давайте перейдемо
далі так спочатку що це ми
називаємо головоломкою давайте запишемо добре якщо
подивимося на цей знак
так плюс Дада Ваня ми його називаємо  додавання
Браво
тож ходімо далі, у нас також є проблеми
та рішення страва з трояндами для лазаньї Аня, ти
прийшла і у нас є багато різних
формул, і остання буде
відсоток,
тому з відсотком горілки давайте
переглянемо алгебру слів головоломка додавання
формули рішення та відсотка
дякую, давайте рухатися далі,
готові, давайте, чи
можете ви вгадати тему Браво, це
геометрія, тож давайте запишемо назву
добре, щоб слова асоціюватися з
геометрією, щоб форма g  ну чи можемо ми отримати цю
форму, що це, Браво,
це трикутник, так
теорема про різні форми теорема рамену добре, давайте
з площею, що таке площа, добре зроблено,
ми також отримали периметр та об'єм,
так що площа периметр периметра площі,
об'єм OPM, давайте
продовжуємо спробувати вгадати  це ви можете вгадати
браво це українська мова або
українська і це речення, то
спочатку давайте назвемо ці частини
мови, щоб ця була підметним
пігментом або ми також скажемо маніакальний давайте
перейдемо далі двома рядками
це дієслово добре  як щодо цього, ми
називаємо його об'єктом Datak bravo, а що
щодо цього дуже рядка, це
прикметник,
добре виконано. Я збираюся використовувати скорочену
форму прикметника, а що щодо цього,
будь ласка, залиште прислівник Nick well done, щоб у нас
був об'єкт дієслова  прикметник і
прислівник які інші слова асоціюються
з українською мовою, оскільки українська
мова є предметом звичайно
добре, тому речення давайте для мене це
також суфікси та префікси
досконалий і це'  s анонсував випадки з
молоком у Великобританії синоніми та антоніми, а
тепер давайте переглянемо слова з
української так підмет-дієслово-об’єкт
прикметник і прислівник добре виконано
суфікси та префікси речення відмінки синоніми та
антоніми Браво, тож давайте розберемо ще дві
загадки, почнемо з першої
чи вгадаєш це легко Браво
це хімія давайте запишемо назву,
щоб слова асоціюються з
хімією давайте спочатку запишемо їх
суміш що це розгін
Браво ми можемо реагувати новий вид також у нас
є різні елементи
і елементи зібрані
разом  періодичну таблицю, тож давайте
переглянемо слова з хімії предмет
суміші реакційні елементи періодична
таблиця і останній спробуємо її вгадати,
я думаю, це дуже легко, і всі ви
можете сказати англійською правильно, у нас є дієслово
to be і три форми  це в
теперішньому часі, тож М — наше, давайте
запишемо назву англійська, щоб слова
асоціюватися з англійською для мене неправильні
дієслова okay
nough pr  мабуть, треба це Слава давайте йти
далі Я сказав вам, що ці форми М це наші
це з теперішнього часу, тому
різні часи
можете назвати хоча б пару так теперішнє
просте теперішнє безперервне минуле
безперервне теперішня досконала або минуле
досконало добре зроблено
мій улюблений майбутній давайте  продовжуй, у нас
також є фразові дієслова
okay та ідіоми, звісно, і останній з ни
діалекти, тож давайте переглянемо сл
ва з теми англійські неправильні ді
слова часи фразові дієслова ідіоми та ді
лекти, добре зроблено, тепер давайте пограємо в не
елику гру Я збираюся очистити до
ку  тому ви не бачите слів, і
я дам вам слова, які
асоціюються з предметом, і ви
назвете предмет,
давайте спробуємо добре, так давайте спробуємо, коли я кажу
формулу добре, можливо,
хімія є предметом фізики
предмет або, ймовірно, геометрія та алгебра
- це добре зроблено, давайте спробуємо
інший періодична таблиця дякую це
хімія,
коли я кажу фразові дієслова та ідіоми
англійська добре виконано, коли  Я кажу
периметр площі та геометрію об'єму Браво, коли
я кажу сила чи енергія фізика добре
зроблено,
коли я говорю розв'язання відсоток додавання
головоломки так це математика, а також
алгебра добре,
коли я кажу суфікси префікси відмінки
українська мова англійська також
можлива насправді будь-яка мова предмет
правильно  добре, і остання суміш і
реакція Браво, це хімія,
дуже дякую, хлопці,
тому це буде вашим домашнім завданням,
запам'ятайте та вивчіть нові слова, у вас сьогодні є
величезна база слів, тому запам'ятайте
їх усі, ми збираємося до вас
під час наших уроків  і я чую дзвіночок,
це означає, що нам потрібно припинити урок,
дуже дякую, що приєднався до мене сьогодні
і побачимося наступного разу, до побачення
[Музика]